please please folks Billy Crystal is
late for the Clippers game we've got to
get this show going okay let's get to
the news right quickly unemployment is
unemployment is dead its lowest level in
seven years five point four percent
ladies and gentlemen fighting stuff of
course wait there are still fields where
there are hundreds of desperate people
after the same job like Republican
nominee for president that would be one
of them yes the renew entrance in the
week this week from the Republican side
all gems Carly Fiorina is running for
president Talbot
now cynics not me
cynics say she's just in there big as
the Republicans eat a woman and it's
either her or Lindsey Graham I don't
agree with them then there's dr. ben
Carson dr. ben Carson he dr. ben a
pediatric neurosurgeon the pundits say
his unique insight into the child's
brain makes him a perfect fit for the
Fox News crowd so that he's in that and
then
and then our friend he was here recently
right and that year Mike Huckabee Mike
Huckabee the former of angelical
preacher ran in 2008 did quite well but
you know he says this is not the old
Huckabee oh no this is a new Mike
Huckabee he's now handling snakes
virtually ah oh I like Mike I like my MP
but Mike does believe that we are living
in biblical end times
take that hope open change meet death
and destruction yeah he believes in ed
tons Ted Cruz proves it but but speaking
of end times
what a oh well thank you
apropos of very little but I appreciate
it did you see what happened in Texas
this week what could have been a
horrible massacre was averted someone
down there had the bright idea to have a
draw a Mohammed cartoon contest and
predictably to isis-inspired gentleman
walked in with assault rifles and we're
going to kill everybody and a very smart
cop with a good aim dropped them and
that is pretty big news it's not every
day a cop shoots a black guy who's
actually armed but good for that cop
really also this was the first Texas gun
fight ever to begin with the words don't
draw but you know I know that they're
very touchy in that religion about how
Mohammed you know can't draw him I don't
know why he's not a bad-looking guy I
think if any religion is going to ban
pictures of the founder it should be
Scientology I mean
l ron Hubbard looks like the manager of
a Red Lobster I don't see that as
something that oh there he is
sir but here's something really
interesting one of the gunmen in this
incident grew up in Pakistan he's
actually from Texas born there grew up
in Pakistan when he was in Pakistan this
is what's so weird he was like a
heartthrob in high school he was in the
school plays I'm not kidding he did a
production of Bye Bye Birdie in Pakistan
and another shows he was in Seven Brides
for one brother are you familiar with
that one and anyway he was terrific and
ain't misbehavin you know that it's very
good but um but the FBI said they were
aware of him but they had to let him go
because he hadn't done anything really
bad you know like under-inflated
football talk about dominating the news
all week yes deflategate football's 9/11
thank God Tom Brady addressed the nation
last night from The Oval Office no now
in an interview and you know they kept
asking him you know about pounds per
square inch of air in the football and
the exact instructions you gave the
equipment manager and at one point Tom
looked right in the camera he said you
know our team has a tight end who killed
a guy right
I mean
to report from the Commissioner's Office
on deflategate was 243 pages Bruce
Jenner has given less thought to balls
and let's and let's end this monologue
type with some very good news in
Baltimore this week no riots no unrest
cooler heads prevail yeah because people
there said they were inspired when they
saw how Mayweather and Pacquiao could
get along without fighting